let's go next to ivan from
phoenix arizona ivan you're on the air
hi david how are you good um so i'm
currently
a senior in high school okay um and
recently i've been paying attention to
uh like the local elections
over here in i'm actually in gilbert um
but like also the politicians here and
uh i've realized that like a lot of them
are extremely slimy
um people i'm just curious how i
can get more involved to make sure that
these types of people aren't elected
anymore
especially as um arizona is becoming
more left-leaning
yeah i mean this you know pay attention
to whether there is a candidate that you
find to be not slimy that runs
at the city council level mayoral level
whatever and work for their campaign i
mean there's no
all of these upstart campaigns want
volunteers and if you don't see anybody
who you want to put your efforts behind
consider maybe running yourself at some
point but that's this is exactly the
right question you don't like the people
that are representing you
um and so you have you can have a voice
in that and that means not only can you
will you be able to vote i don't know if
you're already old enough to vote not
only will you be able to vote
you can run you can support other
candidates you can draft other
candidates and say to someone you should
really run against this person so yeah
the local level is where you can
actually
have the biggest and fastest impact in
many ways
yeah that's what i was thinking um last
year i had the opportunity to go to the
capitol
um for like an environmental day and
speak with uh
the my con uh my representative
um and he just started questioning like
the sources
our biology books came from oh my god
yeah it was like an absolute mess um so
i just want to make sure like these
types of people
aren't able to have any power you know i
just
recently was reading that the the most
dangerous state to be in from the
standpoint of the pandemic
is arizona have you does that resonate
with you in terms of what you've seen
oh yeah it's a complete mess here um
people don't wear masks in stores like i
work at a walmart and
probably one-third of the people aren't
wearing masks when they're inside
um schools nobody wears masks it's
it's just really bad here and how about
as far as vaccines are you hearing a lot
of anti-vaxx talk
um actually i haven't heard too much um
anti-vaxx talk
um just more so people still believing
that the virus
is just a democratic hoax
well the weird thing about that is you'd
think then it would have ended when joe
biden was sworn in
yeah i mean i my my uncle kept saying
that
come november 3rd the coronavirus is
going to be over
right okay here we are have you talked
to him and asked what happened
uh i haven't actually um we don't have
the strongest
relationship okay yeah i can guess why
yeah
yeah all right well listen ivan you're
asking all the right questions you're
doing all the right things it's great
that you're involved
well thank you very much david all right
ivan from phoenix
fantastic fantastic to have uh
young folks involved very very important